so und jetzt freue ich mich darüber mit
Wolfgang Bosbach CDU Urgestein zu
sprechen danke dass Sie zu uns gekommen
sind grüß sie
schöne Grüße aus Bergisch Gladbach Herr
Kohle sehr das freut mich sehr also das
was sie da erlebt haben gestern Abend
waren sie da Abteilung ach du lieber
Himmel oder Abteilung nach mal gucken
wohin die Diskussion führt
ich war in der Abteilung es wird nicht
lange dauern bis sogenannte
Parteifreunde sich Friedrich Merz zur
Brust nehmen werden obwohl er gerade
nicht gesagt hat dass wir unsere Haltung
als christliche demokratische Union
ändern und dieser Haltung heißt keine
wie auch immer geartete Zusammenarbeit
keine Koalition keine Kooperation mit
der AFD aber was es in den letzten
Jahren übrigens auch von SPD und Co
gegeben hat einzelne Abstimmungen auf
kommunaler Ebene wo man tatsächlich
gemeinsam mit der AFD gestimmt hat das
kann übrigens keine Partei ausschließen
dass das nicht geschehen kann und für
die Union stellt sich die Frage wie für
andere Parteien auch wenn die CDU
irgendwo in einem Kommunalparlament
einen Antrag stellt und die AFD droht
mit Zustimmung soll die CDU dann den
Antrag zurückziehen das ist eine
wichtige Frage die wird aber irgendwie
bisschen eigenartig unter teilweise auch
hysterisch teilweise berechtigt
diskutiert dann kommt ja der Hinweis aus
Berlin von der AFD ja wir haben ja auch
den Regierenden Bürgermeister mitgewählt
und so weiter damit muss man sich ja
beschäftigen ist das dann aus ihrer
Sicht eine Hysterie dass man da so drauf
reagiert oder eine berechtigte Frage
weil die Kommunikation war ja schon ein
bisschen naja sagen wir mal dünn er
hätte ja definieren können was meint er
mir Zusammenarbeit oder
Herr Kohle damit haben sie recht er
hätte ein zwei ganz konkrete Beispiele
nennen können wir werden da auch welche
eingefallen Sassnitz auf Rügen Forst
oder Hildburghausen da war allerdings
nicht die CDU betroffen sondern die SPD
aber dann gibt es diese Aufregung
überhaupt nicht und es war in diesen
Fällen so wie es immer ist dass die
Partei zentralen sagen also das Berlin
sagt oh sehr unschön möchten wir nicht
aber es bleibt dann ohne jede Konsequenz
für die örtlichen Mandatsträger und was
bitteschön soll denn der
Parteivorsitzende Friedrich Merz
aus welchen Gründen auch immer in einer
kommunalen Sachfrage CDU und AFD
gemeinsam abstimmen zum Beispiel bei
einer Bebauungsplan oder wenn
gewerbesteuergesetze gesenkt werden soll
soll die CDU dann immer nein sagen warum
sagt ihr Nein ja weil die AFD dafür ist
das ist ein ganz großer Spagat der hier
nicht nur von Friedrich Merz sondern von
allen Parteivorsitzenden gemacht werden
muss also da muss man schon auch sehr
zitiert dran gehen und er sorgfältig
sich vielleicht auch ausdrücken ob man
nun aktiv oder passiv in
Anführungsstrichen zusammenarbeitet und
wo die Grenzen sind da muss man die
Grenzen auch in diesem Fall definieren
würden sie das ihrem Parteifreund März
heute Abend vielleicht noch mal
irgendwie auf zwei Bierdeckel schreiben
ich glaube ich kenne Friedrich Merz
lange und gut genug ich habe sofort
gewusst was er gemeint hat ich sie haben
Recht ein zwei Beispiele hätten da
geholfen aber was mich besonders stört
es gibt nicht wenige in der Partei die
dankbar sind für dieses Missverständnis
in der Kommunikation weil Sie jetzt die
Gelegenheit haben Friedrich Schmerz noch
einmal öffentlich zu kritisieren warum
weil sie ihn eigentlich im Gegensatz zur
großen Mehrheit der Basis nie als
Parteivorsitzenden haben wollten so wird
die CDU allerdings keinen Erfolg haben
Zusammenarbeit heißt für mich eine
Koalition eine Kooperation auf Dauer
oder auf eine gewisse Zeit angelegte
gemeinsame politische Überzeugung dass
sehe ich nicht zwischen CDU und AFD
kommen das wird es auch nie geben weil
die
programmatischen inhaltlichen
Unterschiede zwischen CDU und AFD so
groß sind dass die AFD immer unsere
politische Gegner bleiben wird und nie
ein potenzieller politischer Partner das
heißt wenn die AFD so bliebe wie sie
denn sich derzeit darstellt schauen wir
mal auf ein Beispiel auf einer anderen
Skala nach links geschaut in Thüringen
da wird jetzt gerade etwas lauter schon
diskutiert darüber ob die CDU dort
eventuell mit der Linkspartei
zusammenarbeiten sollte das sind ja auch
so tabutionen wie wie sehen Sie das
nein da gilt das Gleiche obwohl ich
weiter von entfernt bin Linkspartei und
AFD inhaltlich programmatisch
miteinander zu vergleichen aber dieser
eingangs richtiger Weise erwähnte
Parteitagsbeschluss bezieht sich ja
sowohl auf die linke als auch auf die
AFD und es wäre auch widersprüchlich
wenn die Union sagen würde mit der AFD
nie und nimmer aber mit der Firma
umlackierten SED oder mit der SED
nachfolgeparteien können wir uns schon
eine politische Zusammenarbeit
vorstellen nein ist egal wie sich die
CDU verhält ob Sie sich nach links außen
öffnet oder nach rechts außen ich kann
davor nur dringend warnen wir würden in
der politischen Mitte viel mehr
verlieren als wir im linken oder rechten
Flügel dazu gewinnen könnten das ist
doch mal ein klares Statement ähm jetzt
schauen wir mal auf die K-Frage ich weiß
sie werden jetzt gleich sagen doch
machen wir nicht aber an dieser karfrage
sind jetzt ein paar Kratzer dran weil
das war nicht nicht geschickt oder
ja was heißt jetzt geschickt Friedrich
Merz wird sich heute morgen selber
gefragt haben hätte ich inhaltlich
identisch es nicht auch anders
formulieren können um Kritikern
potenziellen Kritikern gleich den Wind
aus den Segeln zu nehmen aber die
K-Frage wird sich zu einem anderen
Zeitpunkt entscheiden und das
entscheidende Argument wie vor drei
Jahren wird sein mit wem hat die Union
die besten Chancen die nächste
Bundestagswahl zu gewinnen dass die
wichtigste Frage und nicht mehr wenn es
unbedingt werden ich danke Ihnen sehr
herzlich Wolfgang Bosbach danke schön
und bis zum nächsten mal vielen Dank so
und wir schalten gleich weiter nahtlos
nach Berlin zu Professor Karl Rudolf
kort ich grüße Sie ganz herzlich sagen
Sie mal die gleiche Frage eigentlich
auch an an sie ist es eine politische
tonübung für sie gewesen oder ein
wohlkalkulierter Testballon was sagen
sie
ja dass wir das nicht genau wissen
verungler hat das Bild über ein
Parteivorsitzenden also entweder ist es
dilettantisch gewesen das wäre die erste
Variante das etwas herausgerutscht ist
aber bei einem sehr
wichtigen sommerinterview auf diesem
Terrain nicht konkret zu formulieren
würde nicht für seine Professionalität
sprechen die zweite
interpretationslinie wäre ja zu sagen
er hat etwas ausgetestet was er bewusst
so setzen wollte gerade in der
Sommerpause kann man das machen um
einmal auszuprobieren aus welchen
Richtungen konkret der Protest kommt
auch das wäre ja eine Variante aber dann
hätte er heute das nicht so korrigieren
können und die dritte ist es ist
letztlich bedeutungslos was er sagt denn
das was er auch gegenüber den Grünen
gesagt hat eine hauptgegnerschaft der zu
CDU zu den Grünen kann ja nicht wirklich
ernst gemeint sein wenn man in Wiesbaden
in Kiel
und ähm
in drei Bundesländern mit der mit den
Grünen zusammenarbeitet also in
Düsseldorf in Kiel und in
Wiesbaden das ist insofern kann ich
ernst gemeint sein dass das ein
Hauptgegner ist wenn man ihn so
zentralen Fragen in einer
Landesregierung immer mit den grün
intensiv zusammenarbeiten muss also alle
drei Varianten sind
diskussionswürdig sprechen aber nicht
dafür dieses hohe Integrationsamt eines
Parteivorsitzenden so wahrzunehmen dass
auch die Mitglieder wissen um was es
geht ja es hat ja eine ordentlich
tatsächlich Kritik gehagelt das ist gar
kein Übertreibung aus den eigenen Reihen
der gab es ja schon sehr deutlicher
Äußerungen von großen Namen einer hat
irgendwie gefehlt ich weiß nicht wie es
Ihnen geht Hendrik wüst z.B
ja das kann unterschiedliche Gründe
geben vermutlich liegt es darin
begründet dass
zwischen beiden ein größere Differenz
interpretiert wird und er das nicht
weiter befeuern wollte das ist eine
Wahrnehmung andererseits sind es alles
nrw-player die sich gut kennen und die
Differenz ist graduell
okay wenn da die Differenz gerade
aktuell ist aber die Richtung die
gleiche eventuell ist wohin könnte Herr
Merz mit diesen Äußerungen gewollt haben
auch wenn er heute die Rolle rückwärts
gemacht hat
die Andeutung
Legitimation durch Verfahren ernst zu
nehmen und so ein
in freien Wahlen demokratisch gewählte
Landrat oder Bürgermeister da kann man
nicht einfach so tun von Seiten der CDU
als wird sie nicht geben dann würde man
sich ja so
regelwidrig verhalten wie es die AFD
hier in ihrem Alltag macht weil es ja
die
antiregelpartei an sich das wenn das
gemeint ist also anzuerkennen dass da
einer legitim gewählt ist dann heißt das
nicht mit ihm zusammenzuarbeiten aber
diese Anerkennung ist natürlich eine
Anerkennung von
Demokratie Prinzipien so könnte man ganz
Wohlwollen das interpretieren dass er
das gemeint hat und das würde natürlich
auch ein Umgang implizieren der sich von
dem der AFD fundamental unterscheidet
denn das ist ja nicht nur eine an die
systempartei sondern sie versucht ja auf
allen Ebenen nicht nur alles zu
diskreditieren was an institutionellen
Verfahren die Demokratie bietet sondern
eben auch sehr offensiv
Regeln zu widersprechen und damit neue
Wirklichkeiten zu bringen
machen das Bild noch mal größer auf die
ganzen Parteien gesehen da gab es noch
eine ganze Menge mehr Reaktionen eben
auch von beispielsweise einem Kevin
kühner dem Generalsekretär der
Sozialdemokraten der von Tabu Spruch
Tabubruch spricht wenn sie auch so weit
gehen
wenn er das nicht korrigiert hätte kann
man das so sagen hätte sich im Prinzip
gegen die eigene Beschlusslage gewandt
der Partei die sie ja vorhin noch mal
herausgearbeitet haben und dann könnte
man sagen eher möchte auch gerne mit
rechtsextremen zusammenarbeiten aber
durch die Korrektur die veränderte
Intonation die neue
interpretationslage kann man das auf
keinen Fall jetzt noch sagen aber es
stellt sich einfach
das Fragezeichen gegenüber einem
Parteivorsitzenden der das nicht klar
genug formuliert hat in dieser doch
politisch sehr sensible
ist der Hinweis von gut das kann man
auch sagen durch beispielhaftigkeit und
wenn damit eben gemeint war dass man
trotzdem Anträge stellen kann wenn man
ein Bürgermeister von der AFD ist als
CDU Anträge stellen darf und bin
zufällig die AFD damit stimmt wenn man
diesen Antrag nicht einfach zurückzieht
sondern nur dann wenn eine Mehrheit nur
zustande käme durch die AFD das ist ein
riesen Unterschied ja und das ist auch
gerade nochmal erwähnt haben er hätte es
vielleicht ein bisschen mit Beispielen
belegen können und man hätte hätte
dieses Jahr doch irgendwie Kommunikation
Desaster oder diese unglückliche
Kommunikation beschädigt die einen
Friedrich Merz oder sagen Sie das ist
heute im Sommertheater geht das
irgendwann weg
nein bei diesen Themen bleibt das eine
Erinnerung das wird auch die politischen
Gegner natürlich
im Wettbewerb weiter immer frisch halten
ein Parteivorsitzender hat nicht nur ein
Integrationsamt sondern er muss ja eine
orientierungsleistung bieten gerade in
diesen Zeiten wo ist das
Alleinstellungsmerkmal der CDU um
kampagnenfähig auch zu werden in
vielerlei Hinsicht und da darf man das
Bild nicht verunplan gerade in der neuen
Grundsatz Debatten Diskussion ist es
wichtig dieses mittige als kernmomentum
konservativer liberaler sozialer
Strömung herauszuarbeiten denn die
Wähler sind mittig orientiert
sicherheitsorientiert moderat orientiert
da sind die kernwähler und es sind sehr
viele die einfach sich dann verunsichert
fühlen wenn man offenbar damit rechnen
muss dass diese Mitte verlassen wird
also
wichtigste Aufgabe des Vorsitzenden ist
neu Orientierung zu geben und nicht zu
verunsichern und das ist mit diesem
Punkt nicht gelogen ein wunderbarer
Schluss hat sich sozusagen